so so you got a new single dropping yeah
and and uh and you're gonna go talk to
dr drew about it yeah when's that yeah
um that's gonna be on monday monday dr
drew's my bro
why are you talking to drew about a
single you're dropping
it's a combo because he's it's got four
years of sobriety and
and so much to say is about my siblings
it's about um
angel
and nick and what they put me through
and nine restraining orders trying to
get a 51.50 on and what's the status and
all the restraining orders now they're
gone they're gone
yeah
the judges told them absolutely not
you're not getting the first time they
gave them they gave them a tro i got
nine restraining orders they took you
know
nine of my firearms away from me three
of my ars two of my shotguns all my pit
mine nine millimeter pistols my throat
my m1a 308.
dude we could make a
uh insane
episode of uh of my tattoo show i would
love to do it
we can ride bikes because
we're talking about something in my ar
can you imagine melting it down that's a
substantial
he wants to melt down the gun and shove
it up his ass
and you're not doing that
that's a lot to fit up your ass
i'll get some of it well you know what
if it was up your butt you know it yeah
maybe a glock but not an ar maybe a
glock
it just struck me now that like wow i
might be trying to bite off more than i
can chew no i i think the tattoo thing
would be great actually yeah dude i
actually want something else on the
other side what do you match up uh well
i wanted to get love and hate
um
do you want to because because
here's the thing though
if if we only understood love we
wouldn't we wouldn't know what hate is
right we only understood hate what
we wouldn't know about lovelace
very important
you know or we can talk about it or it
could be something maybe not love love
not love
i don't know i think i'm pretty much
done with my face tattoos like
i'm gonna load it up and i see like a
lot of these other reels and here's the
thing i'm not a soundcloud rapper bro
like every album i release you know
sells millions so
it's just a part i'm comfortable with my
identity and that's the name of my new
album it's called identity so back to dr
drew you know it's so much to say is
about them and all this stuff and about
my siblings and now it's actually like a
country trap pop song
that's cool so is that the first of its
kind
i mean there's something like it like me
if it's kind there you go
so and then the rest of the records got
it's all
real things like saying how i'm not
perfect and there's another song called
apologize to my family that i did i mean
and
now i just got to record him i've been
going through uh the project i found an
incredible producer morgan matthews my
best friend brian cassidy is writing it
he's on house arrest right now though
for written threat to kill but he's
writing it
um
so
something to say is about your
relationship with your siblings yep
the restraining orders are gone yep um
but it like i saw some like pretty wild
stuff with the
the
the accusations against your brother
nick yeah and all the like police
reports and this and i backed it up
though you know what and you know what
to be honest did anything come of that
did uh no he couldn't sue me for season
to sister slander well right now i'm
saying did anything come of the
accusations no no uh and you know what
listen uh when it comes to that
i don't like it i don't like
what i heard what i seen and what i saw
and
you know my mama's boy
and i just feel like
that
i backed it up with factual evidence so
it is what it is but at the same time
i'm like
should i have done that you know it's an
aggressive move
but but here's the thing i was pissed i
was really pissed at nick because for so
many years he wanted me to get on my
feet and buy a house and all this stuff
and when i did he did not give me the
words of affirmation or accolades and he
didn't say i'm proud of you and
something as simple as that
coming from a family member when you
have such a broken family means a lot
and then also he
you know just
kind of just shunned me over like my
whole adult life you know house card was
he faked to fight or i faked a fight you
know it was a fake fight what on the
show yeah do you ever see that thing
well you know how i know it's fake
and how everyone else should know
he had the blanket over his head and all
the lights were on
and you claim to be sleeping with all
the lights on and blanket over your head
and the camera filming you
and you're like ah you got all your
lights on no that's not how someone goes
to sleep brother
they gonna sleep with the lights off do
you guys talk now i mean was last night
no we don't speak at all the last time
they spoke to me
was
horrible because they had the
restraining orders and legally they
could reach out to me and i can't reach
out to them i can't even respond and
written and this is what happens three
months later after the restraining
orders on christmas day when they knew i
was alone and i celebrate all my
holidays alone i'm
lonely on christmas day
whatever just watching home alone just
trying to enjoy myself and
i get two emails back to back from angel
who had a restraining order against me
and nick
and then they said oh we love you so
much merry christmas
time heals everything
right but that that that's what my
brother said to me after he said oh
allegedly you know
aaron wants to kill my wife an unborn
baby
and then takes pictures of me
unloading my guns out of my car at my
last address
and then takes it into court and says
and has his attorney say look at aaron's
at you know in vegas unloading his guns
and then my attorney goes your honor
aaron's address is in the back of the
picture
in california
and
so it's it's such a complicated
situation it really is and that's
something i want to talk to doctor drew
about
yeah is that that's who i i want to say
hey dr drew
what do you think in your your realm of
expertise as a doctor not a tv
personality
what do you think because
you know
i
apologize to my brother and i'll say
that right now it's the first time
for
letting his skeletons out of my closet
okay because
and letting the skeletons out of his
closet because i'm the kind of human
being that i like to be held accountable
for my actions
if i do something wrong i'll tell you
i'm doing it wrong
or you'll just you'll know and then i'll
admit it to you you know i don't lie
does he know you're having a baby
of course they haven't reached out but
they sent these messages right but
i would never talk to nick ever again if
i heard a rumor
from an ex-girlfriend that i broke up
with that out that nick wanted to kill
melanie and our unborn baby that's about
to be here in seven days i would never i
would never send him a christmas message
i'm just you'd just be cut bro but
here's the thing if i had responded to
angel's message she's that she sent
or nix
2.5 years for each one
in jail
what if you break your restraining order
at that time i would that would be yeah
the strainer
for years but so are you saying
and then they email me and if i and then
if i responded
i sent it to my attorney she says
unfortunately they know that they can
send messages to you and that you cannot
reciprocate anything or else each
message you respond to is 2.5 years in
jail damn
are you saying
you understand where nick is coming from
that if someone told you that and you
believed it
you know
that you would you would probably react
the same way towards you no i'm saying
like he's saying that nick sent him a
christmas message after no that i get
that again but you're saying like if
someone told you keep it off the
internet like yeah like come on dude why
are you putting it on the internet
you know right before i went to rehab
he tweeted oh if you need root hub hope
after i got
arrested for a dui
and then that got dropped i didn't get
to have a dui because it wasn't driving
under the influence and just hadn't been
asleep for two days
and i was driving to the next venue in
alabama he tweets oh if you need help in
rehab let me know dude come on right
don't tweet and then i said to him i
said why did you tweet that oh i didn't
have your number okay then dm it bro
yeah like don't put it out there to make
yourself like this knight in shining
armor for sure and that you're superior
to everybody else in your family just
because and
sorry nick but
bro
you've had like three felonies homie
what are his felonies he's had like four
duis oh yeah
like
you know
like
he he
he allegedly beat up paris hilton
oh damn
you know
i wasn't there around i was there but i
didn't see that but
that's what she claimed
and she put it out to the world
you know
and so a lot of his behavior i didn't
like i don't like i don't i didn't like
how he always tried to act like a father
figure but wasn't i tried to act like a
brother but didn't know how to be a
brother you know and then i dealt with
so much bullying and torturing when i
grew up like they were throwing me in
water moccasin pits and you know
take me 75 miles an hour tubing like and
you know the danger of this kind of
stuff like
75 miles an hour tubing
i had to fall off you're gonna stop
putting a chicken in your
jaw alligator pits well my first ever
surgery i was from a tubing accident
[ __ ] really where you go would you break
there you go i didn't break anything i
had a hematoma in my leg and they had to
open it up to yeah
that's that scar wow
okay so i was going pretty good i was
probably doing 70 75 60 70 yeah it was
when they whipped it and and uh because
if you're on the tube your legs are
hanging off
kevo
david
my buddy camo and uh because i was like
oh steve thinks he's a stunt man
wouldn't we'll still have it and then
when they when you whip like you go
around faster and like my leg hit like a
log in the water or something oh you hit
a log i mean because even just the water
waters
so like they're like doing that like
there's coral reefs around there's you
know
[Music]
it it could slice you open a little bit
and then you know
you all of a sudden you'll have the
lemon sharks and the bull sharks right
on your ass
uh
you know shark diving is it's we would
get on the front of like the carolinas
gifts and we would jump on the on a
lemon shark and flip them over and
paralyze and throw them in the boat and
eat them damn
um
if your brother was here would you ever
do a podcast with your brother to hash
things out or is it a lot deeper than
that he would never do it he stayed he
does the silent game
he trolls me so hard he just released a
song when he knows i'm releasing a song
when i was doing the boxing thing he was
posting pictures of him doing boxing
when i came back out after the
fantastics and i started touring again
and making
good money
i i had a song
album called aaron's party so i called
that the tour the after party well nick
just got finished doing a tour called
the after party so he's non-stop copying
and trolling his little brother and bro
you're 42 years old
leave it alone
obviously we don't get along obviously
you know i'm going to be 34
in less than a month
and
there is there is no reconciliation to i
i'm not even asking for an apology
because they try to get a 50 150 on me
mm-hmm
steve had that yeah i had that steve had
a 52-50 yeah yeah i did
50 150 is a 72-hour involuntary
psychiatric hole 52.50 is a
wow voluntary so i don't know that and
what so when you go in there that's what
happens when you show up for you when
they process you in for your 51.50 and
you spit on people and trying to throw
furniture they change you to 52.
you get to upgrade
well i mean it was crazy because i you
know and then and then i saw like
i was going on live instagram live a lot
and just you know
you know i'm doing no adam 20 uh no i uh
uh no jumper out on 22 and vlad tv and
doing just different those were
legendary interviews yeah and i got more
coming up i got on the 29th interview
i'm doing with vlad tv again cool and
then i'm reaching out to do you know um
no jumper again and then yeah the adam
22 guy yeah
he was a little bit combative
i agree yeah i agree i agree i agree
that they all are trying to get under my
skin for the most part besides yeah
besides you you've been the only one
that actually i'm not trying to get
under anybody's skin or like you know
my life is controversial though
i think it's it i think it's fascinating
you know i think it's fascinating like
the the the phenomena of hearing your
interviews have have been
like they've been they've been they've
been the logan paul one was particularly
impactful yeah particularly crazy yeah
it was because that's when i first
revealed about all the stuff with the
rape stuff allegations with my brother
that was on logan paul yeah yeah
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus has come
into your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude